this remote village in the eastern Czech
Republic is the location of the new
reality TV series on Czech Public TV
it's called holiday in the Protectorate
the show sends three generations of a
family back to the time of the Nazi
occupation a company constantly by
cameras they're supposed to be
recreating the circumstances in the
protectorate of bohemia and moravia
after Germany invaded Czechoslovakia in
1939 the show is based on German TV
Schwarz Bauhaus or earlier British and
u.s. historical reality series the
family was told only that it will be
living sometime in the past 400 families
applied for the role they may have been
attracted by the prospect of receiving
around thirty five thousand euros for
the 60 days of filming the seven members
of the family that won the casting tests
are not professional actors but all the
other figures are like the Gestapo
informers who make the family's life a
misery and the other characters
directors or as ncover came up with the
idea for the program she says it's not
just entertainment but a kind of history
lesson for all those who didn't
experience the period 76 years ago
Halle Dharma yuck holiday we're trying
to find answers to the question of how
people dealt with the situation back
then how did they react the area where
the series plays was the location of
fighting during the war
check partisans attacked German troops
who in turn took revenge on the local
people the Gestapo was based in the next
village I think this project has its
value in the way it seems authentic and
that it was made with great historical
care the viewers learn a great deal
about life in the Protectorate we used
archive material and we've tried to put
what takes place in the house into
historical context should she he studied
ski service la Steve critical reactions
to the show have been mixed it's also
divided the plucky's while yearly plucky
of the military history Institute
defends the show with arguments like
those of the director his wife Pavla a
historian takes a different view
Natalie command the dear Alan Watson and
samuri of course they can't simulate the
real situation I think it's nonsense to
do that it's a game and it remains a
game the experiences of the people who
lived back then can't be conveyed today
you can't compare reactions today with
the reactions back then because the
people are living in an entirely
different context
the more damning criticism comes from
Jana Vera's lava a spokeswoman for a
Czech organization of freedom fighters
who resisted the Nazis the years of the
Protectorate from 1939 to 1945 were a
very difficult time for Czechs and
Slovaks from our point of view it's
completely impermissible to turn it into
a reality TV series it's an insult to
the people who fought for our freedom
back then she's a little boy Ali
nonetheless the Czech public broadcaster
which is airing the 8 episodes in a
prime time slot sees the show as a big
draw the Nazis and Czech resistance to
them are an attraction more than seven
decades after the events